this is a big story because they're
looking for these convicts in upstate
New York and the craziest thing as I
said is that this is the police are
describing the fugitive as well and
doubt and I just think you've never have
you ever heard the battle it was crazy I
had no idea why they're calling him that
yeah how does that help anything I have
a pretty good idea why they're calling
you Matt I just don't know why Jermaine
yeah what what is that how does that
help find this guy and I'm worried why
are they mentioning it is this a new
trend in crime reporting I'm starting to
think it is take a look at these recent
news reports and a daring robbery at a
local bank a man with a very small penis
robbing 80s movies an entire hose
probably to overcompensate for his teeny
tiny penis these are currently in
pursuit of a white pickup truck the
driver is described as a white male
within uncircumcised penis suspect is
racing through traffic past penises of
various shapes and sizes penis there as
you can see and another penis there
almost too many penises count police
released this sketch of one of the
robbery suspects he was last seen
wearing a skull cap and glasses they've
also released this sketch of his penis
the doctors described as impressive and
neatly groomed
I know what they're doing you know you
know what's crazy
what I know that left wasn't that a
great clip subscribe to my youtube
channel for an endless supply of me
[Laughter]